اما ميدانيه وفي اخر التطورات المتعلقه
بالعمليات العسكريه والحرب الدائره التي
تنفذها روسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه قال
احد الضباط في قوات لوغانسك المواليه
لروسيا بان القوات الاوكرانيه حشدت اعدادا
كبيره من الجنود والاليات العسكريه حول
مدينه
اشتد القتال بالقرب من فديه وهي بلده تقع
على خط المواجهه في شرق اوكرانيا حيث
تحاول وقوته الروسيه تطبيقها كما قام
الجيش الروسي بتنفيذ هجوم على بدله
رزودولف في مقاطعه دوناتسك خلال الساعات
الاخيره
اعلنت سلطات وزابريجيا الموليه لروسيا ان
شاء خطا دفاعيه عميق ومحسن لابشالي اي
تقدم من الاوكراني وقالت في بيان لها ان
بناء الهياكل الدفاعيه على طول الخط
الامامي في زابوريجيا على وشكل انتهاء هذا
وتواصل القوات الاوكرانيه قصف مواقع
وتمركزات القوات الروسيه بالمدفعيه
ويتبادل الطرفان الاتهامات بتهديد سلامه
المنشاه النوويه هناك
[موسيقى]